hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game from round 11 of the Lindo
rossabi rapid challenge it's a game
between Ali Riza fiducia and Magnus
Carlsen two two rivals who will be
battling it out for a very long time and
it's quite the game but this is not a
position from their game this is
actually a position from the previous
round from round 10 which was played
between Magnus Carlsen and Daniel dubab
dubab with the black pieces here but
before we check that out a little bit of
drama from the chess world here is a
tweet by Magnus Carlsen he tweeted it I
think somewhere before or maybe during
the the rounds maybe maybe during round
9 or something I'm not really sure about
the time well okay there it is at 3:49
p.m. he says we distributed the Magnus
Carlsen
to removes widely but having
participants repackage as competitors
brand in own stream is not OK tagging
Hikaru Nakamura in his tweet the problem
is well the problem the thing that
Magnus is referring to is that chess
calm is using Nakamura's twitch channel
to broadcast at the tournament which is
organized by chess 24 so now I believe
Magnus and the the good people at just
24 don't enjoyed that so here you can
see that alexandra boat is and Robert
has commentators for chess that calm are
using Hikaru's channel to commentate on
this event that is organized by chess 24
and also their day of course have their
logo chess calm in the in the graphical
interface so I don't know if that's like
I don't think it goes against any any
laws or if it breaks any I don't know
guidelines it could be could be of may
be distasteful a little bit but I don't
even know I'm not sure because they're
not really I mean it's pretty much the
same as if he Cara was just streaming on
his channel to to broadcast the duel
indoors ABI rapid to challenge
tournament so this way I guess Magnus is
saying that since Hikaru is already
playing in the tournament that he can't
stream it on his own channel but
says calm I guess which is pretty weird
it would mean that whenever he car was
playing in a tournament that he should
not be you know streaming or well in
this case sort of stealing viewers but I
don't know I'm sure there's like there's
like people who are much more qualified
to answer this but it is very
interesting there's it's never boring in
the chess world so that being said we're
first gonna show the final position from
a game ten this is a Magnus Carlsen
versus the Neil dubov and here do both
play Knight to c3 he wanted to exchange
the Knights and the Magnus just played
Bishop to f2 he completely blundered the
PC or dubov captured the knight and
that's it Magnus resigned the game which
put puts Magnus in a really
uncomfortable position as in the final
round against ali reza who has the white
pieces Carson is on the verge of
dropping out of his own tournament
because if he doesn't qualify in the top
eight into the knockout phase he's out
of the tournament luckily for him both
him and ali reza need a win at qualify
for the for the knockout phase Magnus
could be satisfied with the draw hence
hence the title something young
Gustafson said you were during the
stream so he might be satisfied with the
draw now had to qualify for the knockout
phase but I don't know if that's like a
hundred percent correct with like maybe
maybe in most scenarios but okay yeah
that being said and yeah I mean it's um
that whole piece blunder I mean everyone
can blunder of course everyone can blunt
but a world champion blundering a full
piece like out of nowhere it just
doesn't happen that often but it's I
know when when my Chess Club and myself
we go to play against another chess club
a club and then we're like who's gonna
drive and I'm like no I can drive I mean
I I have to focus on the game and the
Magnus he's doing the really a lot a lot
of different stuff he has the plane
Magnus he he's now either the co-owner
or a shareholder in chess 24 I don't
know how that works but he has a he has
a lot of stuff going on so we have to if
you have to worry about organizing stuff
if you have to worry about are you
getting views are you you know a lot of
stuff other than the chess game then I
don't think you can be a hundred percent
in the chess game so that's I I think
that maybe one of the explanations as to
how a world champion can one draw a
piece like that
but okay I'm sure there's a there's a
reason for everything so that being said
let's finally check out the game so all
it is a with the white pieces who also
needs the wind goes for night of three
the ready opening and ever since my lost
loss against MVL that terrible loss if
you haven't seen it you can check it out
there's a link in the description below
I did study the ready a little bit
especially the d5 variation however my
studying will not be very useful as
course and goes g6 already and move to
and I have no idea about this line so I
can't really give you any insight but as
I am starting up on the red team I might
you know make a video on how to counter
the ready one once I'm done if you guys
would enjoy that but getting back to the
game we have c4 cousin captures and now
Knight to the a3 preparing to recapture
with Knight to c4
Magnus Fincher effing heroes the dark
square bishop we have Knight captures in
c4 and now Knight to c6
we have d3 our continuing development in
now 'if I've by Magnus grabbing more
space since entered the shop D to
preparing Bishop to c3 and now Knight G
to e7 Magnus is now ready to castle and
now h4 the Alexander Greek move who he
played it twice most notable game is
against Janna publishing the World
Championship 2018 wear nipple also
continued like Magnus we have h6 Bishop
to c3 now putting the bishop on this
very nice diagonal f6 and now Grisha in
their match against nipple up late
nights that III but here we have Bishop
to g2 which is a new move by Edessa
so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game and yes never wanted
game against the Grisha in the 2018
World Championship so Bishop to e6
continuing development and now both
players Castle we have castles battle it
is a castle by Magnus and rook the c1
continuing development and now a5
grabbing more space in them on the Queen
side preparing maybe 5 B 4 and so on
so Queens the 8 sorry that's not a Queen
Queen to a for not allowing b5 right
away in Queen to d7 now at developing
the Queen connecting rooks and maybe
ideas like Ruby 8 to B 5 B 5 come to
mind
so rook F to D
by Allah Reza but now not rook the rook
F to beat but rather looked at b8 by
Magnus and okay with a three by holidays
and now b6 so not not going for this
rook to b8 the b5 but rather more of a
not really doing anything anything
decisive we're just gonna you know keep
everything at bay and make the game
lasts as long as possible without too
many exchanges as I would really enjoy
winning this game so III biologist and
now rook a to be it now threatening b5
to win win some material here and here
the situation on the clock was some
eight minutes ali reza and 11 minutes
Magnus well it as it goes back Queen to
c2 he doesn't want to meet b5 with the
Queen still on a4 and now a for Magnus
just grab some more space prevents any
b4 ideas the idea is the same of course
you cannot capture a point as you black
again wins material so after a for now
we have Knights to e1 by Allah days on
opening up at this bishops diagonal and
also adding another defender to the d3
pawn we have b5 by Magnus and now Knight
the d2 going back but the knight can
find a very nice outpost on e4 which
Magnus kind of prevents with Bishop to
g4 asking now do you wanna further
weaken your pawn structure on the King
side would have three do you want to
trade bishops do you wanna you know
block with the night which is what all
it is so does he goes night the detail
three and Magnus just goes back Bishop
to e6 hence the title saying that I
might be satisfied with a draw I'm not
saying I am but I might be are you
satisfied with a draw which means that
you are out of the tournament if you
draw the game so it's an incredibly
unpleasant position for Ali Reza he he
knows that he could probably repeat and
maybe get a draw against Magnus but he's
a it also means he's out of the
tournament so ali reza goes Queen to b1
which is you know it's a move but now
Magnus goes Bishop to b3 now puts
pressure on the rook at night to see two
blocking and now Quinta a six now or
with some ideas of Bishop to a2 really
getting the queen or a game we have
Knights to d2 biology's I'm now saying
I'm offering the d3 point if you're
interested and it is very complicated
for example if rook characters on d3
Allah Reza has
the beef or not with an attack on the
rook with a double attack on the night
here Knight character son the bishop is
an idea which would open up an attack
against the roof Queen captures and III
is an idea so everything is hanging here
and you have you have a lot of options
here but let's say you go back look D to
d8 now you just go Knight captures nb3 a
captors and night to a6 you go after the
rook after the rook moves you can
capture for example here or you can
capture here and then capture on c7 or
if the the route blocks the night to c5
winds material here so it's a very
unpleasant so you don't want to grab
this point on the other hand if you go
Bishop a to Queen a1 first to really get
to the Queen out of the game and then go
rook captures on d3 it's still night
before again with an attack on the rook
and now okay you can capture now since
the queen is not attacking the rook
however after Bishop character son b4
black can go Bishop to d5 for example
but then it's a very very unpleasant for
your rook for example if you try to get
the bishop out it in you can just trap
the rook with Bishop to f1 let's say and
the rook has nowhere to go so it's a it
is a poisoned pawn which Magnus of
course doesn't capture he goes Bishop to
d5 offers a trade of light square bishop
and here we have Knight to e4 Alireza
and doesn't trade a time right away and
he gets an excellent square for the
knight which Magnus immediately
dislodges with f5 with Knight to c5
attacking the Queen and Queen f7 still
keeping keeping an eye on the White
Queen so e for now attacking the lights
were Bishop F captures F captures on e4
d characters and now Bishop to a2 not
losing a move as it comes with tempo
Queen to a-1 and now this should be back
to c4 and here you could try something
like let's say rook captures on the a
drop characters and rook to d1 but then
black really gets a nice outpost for the
night which if you want to eliminate
then you just give black a a passed pawn
and it's a it's a very it's a very nice
position for black so it is a
possibility but alavesa goes for
something else he goes for night the e3
instead and now goes after the bishop
here also nights the d5 might be an idea
in the future
but now comes night to d4 and here
Alireza who is lower and time has to do
something it's not clear how to mobilize
your rooks how to get the Queen into the
game and Magnus's pieces are just
getting better and better so here a
bishop character son before he grabs
some pieces and Knight captures on c4
which gives Magnus a lot of control here
and he does have two connected pawns at
the deep on being a passed pawn and here
is the bullet the genius immediately
finds Bishop to h3 he goes for Bishop to
e6
to win Carson's Queen and rook the d6
now just defending the the e6 square and
here a queen to a - now with a double
attack on the c4 pawn and here Magnus
played a move and he played it instantly
so I feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the move Magnus played
instantly which is the the best move in
the position while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations I'm not
going for any material and for thinking
outside the box and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show it's rook to
b3 not allowing the Queen to come into
the game and it is it is best to just
give up the exchange here if Knight
captures say captures that Queen is not
coming into the game anytime soon Queen
b1 just d3 and you're just you're just
so much better I mean I mean none of the
Queen and the Turks aren't doing
anything here and you also free up the
d4 square for your bishop so it's just
gonna be it's just gonna be an awesome
position for black it it might be
playable in classical but in in rapid
with tell it as a having few minutes on
the clock and not likely
so Allah Reza does basically anything
other than capturing the rook he goes
for Knight character Sunday for at least
he wins a pawn and now creates a past a
pawn which he will start pushing but now
Magnus goes d3 now again freeze the d4
square for the bishop we have nice to
see five attacking the rook and again
Magnus not interested in the rook just a
bishop the d4 we sorry about that just
have to check something
whoo sorry about that
my father brought over some food for
meadow it couldn't wait
but yeah Bishop to the for Boeing after
the DF to pawn and it's quite a problem
for early Reza as the night uncie v is
also hanging so it is it is quite
unfortunate this happened so always of
course went for the rook there is no
better move here night chapters on b and
b 3 and now just Queen captures on f2
with check King 2 H 1 and now Queen
captures and G 3 and the problem is you
can't even save the bishop for example
in Bishop g2 the G 1 square is still
covered by the rest of this is just made
capture special page 3 and characters
with checkmate or if you go
Bishop to f1 then just Queen to g1 is
checkmate so nothing to be done there so
Eliza played rook to d2 at least he will
be able to cover up not to get the
checkmated so Queen captures rook blocks
and now a queen to f3 with check we have
worked the g2 and now not not you know
dwelling on the position too long just
grabbing more material seek after son b3
the Queen finally enters the game but
now black is just much better also up in
material King g7 and now Queen to d1
others are still hoping to play the same
game 2 rooks against the a Bishop Knight
in the rook and Magnus is ok but first
I'm just gonna grab yet another pawn so
Queen e1 and now Queen characters anyone
we're up characters anyone and now
kinked sorry Knights the f5 and here
it's a knight and Bishop and rook
against two rooks with Magnus being up
upon and White's position is just
terrible with the Barenaked King and
everything so h5 battle it is are going
after the g6 pawn but Magnus just
ignores it Bishop to e3 he prepares to
push his past the D pawn HK % g6n adjust
d2
bringing the the rook on e1 out of
commission out the rook is stuck
guarding the past pawn and now Bishop to
g5 preparing to eliminate D g6 bone as
well
we have rooked f2 going after the night
but now King g6 we have a 4 Alireza
starts pushing his past pawn but now
rogue d4
goes after at a5 and rook to a4 and it
was in this position that algorism
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here this rook has
nowhere to go this rock is stuck
guarding the past pawn
you're losing this pawn very quickly
you're gonna lose this one as well so
it's just completely winning for for
black so a very very very well played by
Magnus and he really played against Ali
Reza's will to win because our Reza
maybe could have drawn the game a lot
sooner but if he draws he's out of the
tournament so Magnus knew that and of
course he knew that how it is I was
going to go for the win especially with
the white pieces and everything and in
the end it worked out well for him but
unfortunately for ali reza he is out of
the tournament and there are still some
games being played so i don't know how
that will finish but we are going to
cover more games from day 3 of the
Lindros every rapid challenge and then
we're gonna check out the standings and
and everything so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think I cannot read this but Google
Translate it says it's hello so hard so
I would like to thank hello Zohar
Jeffrey Jeffrey cook Chad Piper our
truck gotta be onion and Martin you're a
Papa Rick for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Lindo rossabi rapid
challenge tomorrow we're gonna check out
a few more games from the preliminaries
and then tomorrow we go into the
knockout phase so I think you'll I will
see you soon and have an excellent the
rest of your day